it's been a rough go for president
Donald Trump with the football world he
first was pushing against the totally
valid expressions of free speech that
were taking place when NFL football
players were kneeling or doing other
types of protests during the national
anthems before games a couple months ago
and now it's carrying over into the
college football world yesterday was the
college football playoff National
Championship game between Alabama and
Georgia Alabama ultimately defeated
Georgia 26 to 23 and one of Alabama's
players although it's not a hundred
percent sure who was caught on camera
yelling F Trump as the players went out
onto the field it just so happens Donald
Trump was at this game but more on that
later here comes the Alabama team and
initially it was alleged that it was Bo
Scarborough who yelled although he has
since denied that it was him and here's
what was heard during the very very
riled up jog out to the field
right let's play it once more for people
again I'm not gonna say exactly what he
said the we are considering these
fleeting expletives that we hope mercy
will be taken upon us for broadcasting
but here's one more time of what it was
that was said so immediately all the
normal stuff you would expect started
right some people saying hey this is
free speech period no other discussion
to be had others saying this is a thug
no doubt racial overtones there as we're
very acquainted with others saying this
player whoever it was was disrespectful
to the office of the presidency if not
to Trump himself yet other people saying
that he was a poor representative of the
University of Alabama and again we I
guess we pat we don't really know who
did this that the player accused was Bo
Scarborough but he's denying that it was
him who said it he denies it but
obviously he could face some retribution
from the school yeah it hurt his draft
potential during the NFL if he was to go
there yeah I don't know ultimately what
the truth is but I actually don't know
how anyone on the side of the trumpets
can credibly criticise this when it is
quite literally locker room talk right
remember when it's so funny when Trump
talked about grabbing by the
you-know-what it happened on a tour bus
before filming a TV show and I think Los
Angeles was something and Trump said oh
that was locker room talk that was a
stretch then this was a football player
literally exiting a locker room before a
football game if anything has ever been
locker room talk it's this Bo
Scarborough or whoever it was yelling F
Trump anyway I hope the headlines
tomorrow aren't Bo Scarborough receives
multiple death threats as a result of
what he said yeah I'm worried that
Donald Trump will confuse Bo Scarborough
with Joe Scarborough maybe I call him
like crazy Bo yeah he thinks this is the
guy who was there when Mika was beating
a bleeding badly bad facelift or
whatever it was that President Trump
said about her interesting things
happening in Alabama dope though a
couple of weeks ago they elect a
Democrat to the Senate and now this but
seriously I'm not offended by this at
all whether you care or not
what a football player or a celebrity or
an actor thinks about the president
that's one thing I genuinely don't
really care but it is absolutely fine to
use whatever venue you have to express
your opinions now it might have
consequences right freedom of speech is
not freedom from the consequences of
that speech and when a football player
or an actor or whoever chooses to go
political people might not support them
they they might not buy tickets to the
sporting event or buy a ticket to the
movie or whatever but how can anyone
really be offended by this yeah I'm sure
he wasn't thinking about all that when
he said that comment but you probably
didn't think that it was gonna be
captured on television either maybe not
yeah who knows the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as one dollar per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad